[Musique]
invisible au milieu des autres
sa mauvaise réputation lui colle à la
peau
les mauvais souvenirs du salsifié à la
cantine c'est jamais de salsifis blanc
comme celui-ci légumes sans couleur sans
saveur
prenez en faut que je l'ai fait c'était
déclencher de façon à ce que on est
envie d'en manger qu'on a qu'on gomme la
notion que salsifis c'est pas quelque
chose de très sympa décrié le légume
racine creux son sillon en Touraine
[Musique]
j'ai salsifis on les épluchants
Eric roi dixième génération de maraîcher
voyez un peu le temps que ça prend pièce
par pièce c'est pas forcément très
difficile à cultiver mais c'est très
long à préparer à récolter chaque
semaine 2000 salsifis sortent de terre
c'est un légume vivant
ce qui est surprenant c'est la sève sur
ce sur ce légume c'est ce qui est
magique ça pleure tout de suite ça doit
être du plaisir c'est comme la cuisine
et quand on parle de cuisine le chef
n'est jamais loin
qui est don ami restaurateur vient
passer commande
t c'est sûr et certain c'est déjà ce
qu'on peut faire avec ça entre le petit
feuillage le petit collet là tout ça là
ça va être joli les radicelles on a déjà
utilisé le radicel comme ça
proposer à la carte un légume longtemps
volontairement
ignoré par les maîtres de cuisine dans
une farce en accompagnement d'une
volaille dans notre cuisine française
avec une classique il a pas été employé
tant que ça la passe souvent été utilisé
donc c'est vraiment c'est nouveau donc
on peut se lâcher on peut se faire
plaisir c'est il y a de la liberté avec
le salsifis
ou le proposer comme aujourd'hui dans
une entrée viennois de salsifis comme
des mouillettes intitulée principe
décrypter un petit certifie comme ça
c'est allez c'est 30 secondes au
bouillante salé basta et on rafraîchit
voilà alors là je suis en train de
masser avec un petit beurre truffe je le
mets au frigo pendant une demi-heure
pour que pour que le beurre fige un peu
pour soit plus facile à travailler après
il y a cette notion un peu de goût
d'artichaut il y a la finesse de
l'artichaut rouler dans une feuille de
brick on va faire revenir ça gentiment à
la poêle c'est une minute pas plus et
encore voilà et c'est facile ça chante
le salsifis il a cette facilité à
s'adapter à tout quasiment ça se marie
la perfection avec les chairs blanches
de poisson avec une tranche de foire à
chaud de canard alors le jus de poulet
le jus d'orange et un peu d'huile
d'olive voilà ça fait une petite
vinaigrette tranchée ça va être joli ça
va être bon
un peu de truffe
un peu comme ça ça c'est petit saltifice
on a juste blanchi on cherche les
textures là il est nature là donc c'est
ça qui va être sympa aussi de retrouver
là il est vraiment là de cette pure
la revanche du mal-aimé des cantines
scolaires fruit du travail et du plaisir
partagez non à table mais directement en
cuisine
Eric roi a délaissé momentanément la
fourche
[Musique]
pour une fourchette
je suis l'artisan cuisinier qui est
Didier et puis la beauté du geste le
salsifis en majesté
[Musique]
voilà une formule une recette et un
désir donné au plus méconnu au plus mal
connu des légumes racines sur les bords
de Loire terre des rois de France
des lettres de noblesse
[Musique]